let's talk about the apocalypse my
friends we got the story from new york
post billionaire peter thiel's 13.5
million dream home in new zealand is
doomed
it's been characterized as a doomsday
bunker or you know emergency hideout
there's been a bunch of billionaires
that have been talking about the end of
days and wanting to build something in
this story
actually it's i don't know if they have
pictures it's really amazing i mean this
is super cool like it's like hidden the
guys who designed the uh the olympics
in tokyo designed this wow
why are they opposing this actually like
i mean like if you're talking about it
it's like a zoning dispute isn't that
like very inherent with the
with the existing terrain like i had for
the economy but a few years ago i think
there's a cnn article out there that
says this exact area was becoming like a
doomsday prepper paradise it is right
like there's a lot of them out there
matt lauer's there yep yep millionaires
and billionaires have uh first for the
since
like the stories that are coming out
like 2017 after trump gets elected
millionaires and billionaires and i'm
talking about like high-level
millionaires not like somebody's got
like 10 million but somebody's worth
like 750 they're building emergency
bunkers in new zealand they've got one
of the craziest stories i read is that
they carved out mountains with landing
strips so you can fly into the mountain
to land like in
like in kingsman you guys see kingsmen
when they land in the mountain like
so it's like the bad guy wants to kill
everybody because the planet's
overheating is basically like a bill
gates who started a tech company
x and then he's like he's got a lesbian
he's like the planet is heating up and
so it's going to create a virus which is
climate change and it's going to kill
everybody and so he wants to force he
wants to kill everybody to stop that
from happening
so anyway like they land their planes in
this mountain that's i've read stories
about that also you take a look at like
montanan montanning montana
wyoming
tanning spot in montana one state yeah
someone's about to incorporate right now
why amana
wyoming
no we don't need to reduce we need to we
need to make more states there needs to
be eastern west wyoming
right we need more republican senators
yeah we should split west virginia into
east west virginia and west west
southeast virginia
[Laughter]
so so anyway here's i did this as my my
4 pm segment but my question to you guys
is we'll expand this conversation
are millionaires are the millionaires
and the billionaires are they building
this stuff because they know something
we don't or is it because they got money
to kick around and they said why not i
think some might but there's also lots
of people with lots of money buying
places on the coast and they're also
telling us the coasts are going to flood
soon
so maybe some so maybe some do maybe
some don't it's hard to see it's like an
ensure it's like a weird type of
insurance policy you know like yeah
right like i don't think i don't know
teal is necessarily like a giant techno
pessimist like he's doing i mean he does
a lot of other things right he's funding
senators and he has a lot of different
projects but or senate races rather but
it's i mean this strikes me as the kind
of thing that's like okay it's the same
reason some of these people get dual
citizenship and like saint kitts and
nevis exactly yeah he's he's a new
zealand citizen now right so it's like
you
it's just a backup like okay you know
things could get bad right i don't think
he has that's that's that's the question
that's what i'm saying right so you got
a rich dude he's peter thiel's worth 7.7
billion reportedly and so you got that
much money okay
it's gonna cost you 13 million dollars
out of his 7.7 billion
dude he farts that much money yeah
that's a hell yes in my book yeah so he
he's probably like i got to buy some hey
uh bill set up a company and build me
this thing in new zealand yeah i mean
that's about that right like you can
you're making you know if he's got a
billion investments are gonna make like
what eight percent a year generally so
you're thinking you're pl if you're he
just can screw around and play with a
five percent of his net worth every year
okay well seven point seven billion do
the math five bill you know five five
percent of seven billion is what but
don't even i'm not even who even cares
about groups
at 7.7 billion
you don't have to work for multiple
generations like your kids are gonna
have to work yeah so i mean it's yeah i
mean this is just play money right like
that's why he's thinking about having a
meditation space and a doomsday bunker
that's a real luxury that's the last
thing i'd be thinking about in my
doomsday very very small very like
trivial insurance policy for like the
you know hedging against the collapse of
the united states or united states
becoming particularly inhospitable look
at the view is this an actual picture
from his i think it's a mock-up okay
if the view is anything like that then
it's that's better than just an
insurance policy it's a vacation home
yeah are you safe from their prime
minister though even out there in new
zealand because she's like the worst how
does that work
how rich do you have to be to be off the
prime minister's radar i don't know what
her no it doesn't work that way man
i can't remember who we had on the show
talking about
how
wealth is meaningless in an apocalypse
so you think you own something
why
so like anybody who owns a house knows
this why do you own the house because
someone wrote on a piece of paper you
own the house
good luck when some some like a group of
dudes like five guys with shaved heads
and ars walk up and say get out it's my
house and you go but but i have the
paper and they go that's funny i have
the gun
so when the apocalypse happens and
there's nobody to call
he can set this up that's great and then
he can be like i'm rich and i'm a
billionaire and i have this bunker and
the prime minister that crazy lady can
choke with one guy who's got one gun and
they'd be like it's ours now and unless
he's got a way to defend himself that's
an in an apocalypse when everything
breaks down your your deed doesn't mean
anything what you can defend is all that
matters and guess what someone as rich
as peter thiel his net worth will drop
to about
500 000 when an apocalypse happens
because his stocks his his investments
all that evaporate overnight if there's
a global
governmental crisis or collapse and war
breaks out
we've we've not seen something this
extent like even in major wars
you'll still have international like
assets like somebody from britain can
put assets in switzerland and all that
kind of stuff that's probably why
switzerland loved being neutral and
people loved that they were but if we
actually had a total global
breakdown of like international treaties
and stuff
his net worth is is is
what he could hold in his hands yeah
that's who who trusts him and who's
gonna back him up that's a big part of
it maybe crypto well that's why that's
why you try and buy a place in new
zealand you think new zealand i mean new
zealand is super remote right like the
nearest place you can fly to it's
australia and it's a three or four hour
flight it's thousands of miles yeah and
maybe he's banking in the apocalypse the
prime minister just means nothing anyway
right like so he's just okay yeah i'll
go to my i mean and i think the odds of
a universal global apocalypse seem low
right i think again you're hedging
against a united states collapse okay
right
you know yeah man saint kitts and nevis
i think it cost 50 grand to be a citizen
yeah there's there's different like
small caribbean countries that like i
think saint kitts and nevis is like the
biggest one and there and and people the
rich people love that island because
their passports are better than the
american passport because it's an it's
an island nation of like no consequence
so their passports are basically
accepted everywhere because every
country knows you're a rich dude who's
just going to come and spend money in
your country so like whatever i don't
care yeah wow
yeah so you can you can basically
i don't i've never actually researched
this but i've had friends telling me
about
people who that you go there you put you
give them 50 grand and they hand you
your passport you're a citizen do you
guys have dual citizenship or
multi-citizens i have dual citizenship
mm-hmm where's uh germany is it really
when you get yeah uh so i'm half jewish
right and yeah my grandmother had to
leave germany in uh
i don't remember forget is it 38 i think
she left really very late um and so the
german government has a program for
people who like in their view would have
been
born in germany or would have been
german descendants but for
um the nazis that they can apply for
german citizenship for a cheap for
relatively cheap like a couple grand or
something there's actually a bunch of
countries that do things like that
regardless of displacement like if you
are the grand uh son or daughter of
someone who was a citizen who like
emigrated you can apply and and right
i think i think in south korea you can
get a b visa if you're the grand son or
daughter of some of a korean citizen
yeah my wife could do that with greece
yeah because her dad's from greece so
she hasn't but she could well i think
yeah
that's her dad it's like that that's
that feels kind of like it should be
that closer yeah but even a grandparent
i kind of feel like is it is an
extensive right
my grandmother was a german citizen
before she fled right so you know that's
uh
and i mean honestly it's not really that
valuable in the sense of i mean well i
can when i go to europe i get to go
through the short line if i have my
passport with me and yeah conceivably if
i wanted to go work in the eu
other countries though like what about
iran
um
i don't know i mean might be it might be
easier for countries that have a
particularly hostile relationship in the
united states like i probably i think
german passports can get into
iran when united states passwords can't
what was the story with your grandma
bailing she was full jewish in 1938 nazi
germany what's she
their family had you know had plenty of
uh
i don't know exactly i actually don't
know the story of exactly how she got
out but i assume it's one of those like
she managed to cross the border or she
38 30 i think at 38 might be 36 but i
think 38. um i can i'll check with my
mom um but yeah i mean it's a simple you
know that's actually you know not an
uncommon story where
you know the her family at the time had
you know businesses and you know a
reasonable amount of money and they just
abandoned it all showed a penniless in
the united states
um and uh this is just before the war
yeah was she there for this knocked
i would say i was in 38 yeah i would
think so i think that that's
maybe that was like a hey maybe we
should get out of here right yeah she
would have been
i mean she would have been only about 20
right or 20 like she was she was pretty
young i think she was born in like 19
19 19 maybe
um so she would have been very young but
she uh yeah or maybe even younger it was
uh it was crystal knocked was november
was 9th and 10th of november 1938. okay
so maybe before that then i i don't know
but like i know that
she got out pretty late and uh it was
you know that's still you know and i
still like it's funny i mean essentially
i think most of that generation of my
family has passed at this point this is
this is the crazy thing right your your
grandmother got out before
the these violent attacks and stuff like
that i think so and i wonder
you know i don't want to compare what's
happening in the united states to
directly to a lot of these other
countries and other historical moments
because history doesn't repeat it rhymes
but i wonder if you know looking at the
summer of love with 30 around 30 deaths
billions of dollars in damage and mass
rioting from far left ideological
extremists
i don't think is as bad as what this was
this was seriously crazy but i'm
wondering if we're getting to that point
where people are going to start being
like hey maybe we should we should move
from here and i'll put it this way i
left new york to south jersey left south
jersey to west virginia because seeing
the increasing violence for people who
are in germany germany is a lot smaller
in the united states in the united
states if you're watching crisis happen
in your cities you can go to the country
to get away from it but i'm kind of
wondering you know with the trajectory
we're on right now this is the crazy
thing right report from real clear
investigations the fbi team that led the
raid on trump's house was the same team
that led the russia collusion
investigation the hoax so this sounds
like
this sounds outright like a rogue
conspiracy or something like that thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 p.m and if
you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there
you